in a healthy Society female Combat
Sports give me an example of them a
female combat sport like like Gina
carano's stuff should be banned oh yeah
he's just gonna move 100 I actually
think that yeah I think things like UFC
are probably immoral in and of
themselves even for men yes I'm willing
to change my mind on this yeah but it
seems to me that if I'm going to risk
imposing serious bodily damage to you
yeah that I need to have a good reason
to do that and money and entertainment
are not what about Vision what about
football I don't know how to answer that
I agree I don't want to see women beat
each other up in fact a famous female
fighter is a friend of mine you know
Gina Carano who's been on this show but
and Gina Carano could probably punch me
through a wall I'm sure she could button
too but uh but I don't want to see women
being hit no I just don't like that yeah
yeah I agree I agree you're right you
answered right for both of us